Please welcome Mr. Rory Scovel!
(audience applauding and cheering)
Wow.
Lotta people are like, "Should we know him?"
Yeah.
You took the longest time...
We've had presidents on the show
that don't take that much time--
Yeah.
to get to their seat.
I don't ever get this,
so I really wanted to soak it up.
(audience applauding and cheering)
You know what's amazing?
You didn't have a beard when you started to walk out here.
No, no.
(laughing)
God, that feels good, thank you, thank you.
Oh, you son of a bitch.
Thank you.
We got a lot to talk about.
Could it just be this the whole time?
I just keep saying thank you
and people are like, "I like this guy."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
There's so much to talk about.
I haven't seen you in a while, and always
you've been one of my favorite stand-up comedians.
You're a hilarious man.
Thank you.
Then, out of the blue, you get the role
of Amy Schumer's love interest.
Yeah.
How did that happen?
Accomplished actor, they begged, begged me to do it.
You guys know me, I'm in everything.
Literally, it fell from the sky, somebody fell out,
(laughing) couldn't do it, and they were like,
"Who's available and very low priced?"
That's how I basically--
I love the way you sell yourself to a crowd,
I have to say.
(audience laughing)
Well they already applauded for me.
(audience applauding and cheering)
They already applauded, now it's time
for them to know the truth.
So anyway, where were you, where were you?
I was at my house, I was with my daughter.
My wife was gone to do a play for like two weeks.
And I'd just put my daughter down for the night.
Yeah, I got an email from my agent.
He was like, "Read this script, do you wanna do this?"
I'm also like, don't I just say yes?
Am I at the point where I read anything?
Let's just say yes.
You're an automatic yes.
(laughing) Yeah, so I'm reading it,
and I've known Amy through through stand-up for a long time
and she had texted me, she was like,
"It looks like this is gonna happen," I'm like,
I don't even know what's going on, I don't know any of this.
And then three days later, I flew to New York
and we started shooting a film.
I'm in a film.
Yes, you are.
You know, what's funny, well, it's not funny,
but people love your performance, and now you're showing up,
they do, they love your performance.
And I didn't say that was the funny part, but now
these comments come out online,
like this one, this website wrote this about you,
and I think we have it here, Rory Scovel leads
a new generation of sneaky sexy leading men.
And here's the thing,
you know, and when Decider gets the word out
that means it's gospel.
They're decided.
Yeah, but my question is this:
it feels like a back-handed compliment.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I love that it's like sneaky-sexy.
It's like, on the outside, no way.
But then we get to know him, and we're like,
maybe there's somethin' to this guy.
Also leads a new generation of sneakies,
I've done one leading romantic love interest thing,
and suddenly, he's leading a generation of men
who are like, six outta 10.
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
That seems new, that's our fearless leader.
Where's our leader, Average Man?
(audience laughing)
I'm here.